[Musique]
je suis vétérinaire et psychiatres pour
animaux de compagnie en quelque sorte
j'occupe une niche de la médecine
vétérinaire
j'ai passé beaucoup de ma vie
professionnelle à étudier et
l'attachement et l'amour chez tous les
animaux humains ou d'un humain pourtant
dans le langage amour et animale ne vont
pas forcément très bien ensemble on
s'éclate comme des bêtes dans chaque
homme ou un cochon qui sommeille être
comme une chatte en chaleur ou un bouc
en rut
pour certains la part animale qui est en
nous c'est le pire c'est la bestialité
et moi j'ai envie de vous dire nous
pouvons être fiers de la part animale
autre part animale
c'est la base de ce qu'il ya de meilleur
nous c'est la base du mouvement de la
vie c'est la racine de la solidarité et
du partage
c'est le terreau indispensable pour
l'éclosion et la croissance de l'amour
et de l'attachement et là vous vous
dites
le vétérinaire et l'abricot avant de
venir non c'est juste de l'observation
de la science et de l'amour
actuellement la pensée dominante c'est
darwin quand on pense animal évolution
sélection on pense struggle for life on
pense la loi du plus fort alors bien sûr
bien sûr cela existe en chacun de nous
plus ou moins fort de façon plus ou
moins visibles parfois quand il y a une
seule ressource pour deux une seule
place pour deux qui a dit une seule
femelle pour de mal il faut bien se
battre alors on envie d'avoir la
puissance et la beauté du tigre bref la
violence existe dans la nature et l
existant nous aussi mais il n'y a pas
qu'elle loin de là il ya aussi l'amour
à partir du moment où nous parlons
d'espèces dans lequel le lien maternel
existe il nous faut employer le mot
amour quand vous regardez une femelle
mammifères avec son petit le mot
s'impose ce sentiment qui rend un être
saillant dans l'univers qui rend un être
unique pour vous que vous soyez chien
tigre os humains ce sentiment qui fait
qu' il devient possible de risquer sa
vie pour lui qui fait que le moment le
plus doux de la journée c'est quand son
corps vient se nicher au creux du vôtre
vous la paix laurier comment vous
relations à fille hâtive positives comme
voudrait nous faire dire certains
ethnologues relation de nourrissage ou
de soins comme pensée freund qui a
ajouté l'attachement satrape au sein
maternel est il ajouté dans un éclair de
lucidité
je n'ai jamais très bien compris ce lien
qui unit la mère à l'enfant bowlby lui
un théorisé l'attachement il en a fait
une fonction vitale qui existent pour
nous les hommes et qui existe chez
beaucoup d'animaux nous en connaissons
les bases biologiques les hormones
d'abord le site hocine
dont on connaît bien le rôle pour
l'accouchement c'est une petite molécule
qui a de grandes fonctions on l'appelle
aujourd'hui l'hormone de l'amour et de
l'attachement et puis la prolactine
health une grosse molécule et elle va la
halle un rôle important dans la
lactation
mais elle va venir aussi donner un coup
de main l'ocytocine pour rétablir le
lien dans la durée voyez ça comme un
couple les astérix et obélix de l'amour
il y en a un qui interviennent très vite
et de façon courte et l'autre qui va
venir plus lentement mais qui va durer
plus longtemps
à elles deux elles permettent
l'établissement et la pérennisation du
bien et alors vous savez le plus drôle à
tel point que j'allais l'oublier c'est
que les oiseaux aussi ses hormones
existe aussi chez les oiseaux pourtant
aux dernières nouvelles les oiseaux
n'allaitent pas et n'accouche pas et
pourtant ils ont ces deux hormones parce
qu'au-delà du nourrissage le lien qu'il
entretient avec les oisillons est un
lien très fort qui répondent aux
caractéristiques de l'attachement
protection et autonomie du petit l'amour
comme l'attachement active le circuit de
récompense bien connu des spécialistes
de l'addiction
cette partie archaïque du cerveau relie
des noyaux de substance grise dont
l'activation produit une sensation de
plaisir
sensation que l'individu animal ou
humain va s'attacher à retrouver l'amour
donne du plaisir
au point parfois d'en être comme drogué
et cela n'est pas vrai que pour l'humain
c'est vrai aussi pour l'animal ce
circuit de la récompense communique en
arrière avait dit pose à la mousse et
l'amygdale en avant avec le cortex
frontal pour établir un circuit qui
permet de concilier les deux émotions
fondamentales de la vie la peur et le
plaisir est oui
l'émotion primaire de la vie c'est la
peur sans peur pas de vie possible il
faut connaître le danger
il faut apprendre à l'éviter pour
pouvoir survivre et puis au cours de
l'évolution
en même temps que la maternité apparaît
la confiance et ça c'est le contraire de
la peur ce petit qui vient de naître
devrait déclencher chez la mère une
sensation de peur et au contraire la
seule chose qu'ils ont envie de faire
c'est de le protéger non seulement l'un
n'a pas peur mais sonne odeurs les sons
qu'il aimait son contact déclenché l une
immense sensation de bien-être et s'il
disparaît une affreuse sensation de
manque intervient qu elle soit singes
dauphin éléphants ou humain
soudain un être existe dans son espèce
qu'elle aime
par delà tout celui là elles l'aiment
llm de façon inconditionnelle
bien sûr cela fait pareil pour le petit
le petit il est attaché à sa mère autant
que la mer est attaché à lui alors
scientifiquement cela s'appelle
l'attachement
mais pourquoi on s'interdit pour
l'animal le mot d'amour
ce sont nos sens d'abord qui
construisent l'amour chez nous l'odeur
d'un corps le son d'une voix le contact
d'une peau la vision d'un visage ou le
goût d'un baiser dont il pas changer
votre vie à tout jamais dans toutes les
espèces qui connaît ce processus
d'attachement dans leur enfance
elles vont réutiliser ce processus quand
elles sont adultes quand les animaux
font des couples durables comme les
orques vous voyez là eh bien ce sont ces
circuits qui sont utilisés l'autre doit
apporter le plaisir l'autre ne doit pas
faire peur sa présence est douce et
rassurante alors pour les dauphins les
dauphins c'est l'amitié
ce sont les champions du monde de liens
amicaux qui peuvent traverser une vie
oui parce que les dauphins je ne vous
les conseille pas comme emblème ni de la
fidélité ni d'une sexualité douce et
consentants
mais les dauphins c'est un amour ils ne
sont pas très forts l'amitié ils savent
faire et quand vous voyez si vous avez
l'occasion de voir cette image dans la
mer deux dauphins qui sautent ensemble
dans un seau parfaitement synchronisé
alors vous êtes les témoins d'une amitié
qui date depuis très longtemps qui leur
a permis de se connaître à fond et qui
va jusqu au fait que si l'un des deux
est soumis à la taxe d'un prédateur
comme le requin et bien ils vont voler
l'autre va voler à son secours
l'amitié impliquer la solidarité à la
solidarité la solidarité c'est une autre
facette de l'amour c'est aussi une jolie
relation positive
vous vous souvenez de cette histoire
cette gonon qui est tombée sur des rails
de chemin de fer en inde est un mal à
passer vingt minutes pour la réanimer il
va réussir à la sauver juste avant que
le train arrive
certains ont dit intérêts sexuels ou
solidarité d'espèces d'autres y voient
un lien d'attachement
je vous laisse juge le lien ultime de
solidarité pour certains c'est le couple
monogame
les animaux ne sont pas exclu non plus
très rare chez les mammifères donné la
preuve tout à l'heure la monogamie est
quasiment la règle chez les oiseaux
quoique quoique depuis si on va y voir
d'un peu plus près et depuis que les
notamment les analyses
l'analyse génétique nous permettent de
le faire on s'est rendu compte que dans
ces espèces réputées parfaitement
monogame 25% d eux ne sont pas du
compagnon denis et chez les campignol et
chez les campagnols des plaines autres
espèces la de mammifères réputé très
monogame qui a été vraiment un modèle de
monogamie de fidélité un exemple un
10000 publication tout de même
eh bien depuis qu'on fait des analyses
génétiques les résultats sont les mêmes
25% de petites centrales or les
chercheurs qui sont jamais et qui sont
toujours très forts pour 110 bon alors
on va définir deux monogamie un une
monogamie sexuelle et une monogamie
social comme ça même dans la nature il
est possible de faire couple pour la vie
en s'accordant quelques extras mince
alors l'amour éternel noeud supposerait
pas la fidélité est une fois de plus on
ne peut pas convoquer la nature pour
venir témoigner au tribunal de la morale
et son message est un message de
diversité de tolérance
alors j'espère que cet amour qui ne
faisaient amour animal ne fait plus de
doute pour vous cette passion qui peut
venir des humains qui peut venir des
animaux ce sentiment peut même traversé
la barrière des espèces alors j'aurais
pu vous montrer des images d'espèces
parfois bizarres parfois éloignés
parfois même ennemi vous avez des des
montaigu et des capus les animaux qui
s'aiment malgré les autres non
ce que je voudrais ce que je vous
appelle comme témoin c'est ce sont les
chiens qui peuplent mon quotidien et
dans l'histoire avec les hommes s'étale
sur plus de 30 mille ans est une
histoire d'amour
je suis témoin de cet amour de cet amour
fort véritable est réciproque est
aujourd'hui à la recherche s'intéresse
enfin aux bonheurs au positif et bien
les études nous montrent les
conséquences de l'attachement c'est ce
qui se passe par exemple quand un chien
et un humain se regarde dans les yeux et
bien leur taux d'ocytocine femmes dont
celle et 2 mais les chiens
malheureusement parfois peuvent souffrir
de leur amour au quotidien certains
chiens ne supporte pas l'absence de
l'être d'attachement c'est la première
alors ils vont tout détruire ils vont
hurler
ils peuvent soulier ça pourrait presque
parfois prêter à rire encore que quand
on arrive là ça prête pas trop rires
mais c'est la première raison d'abandon
et d'euthanasie pour les chaînes je suis
sûr que
si vous y pensez vous avez un exemple
autour de vous un ami un parent qui n'a
pas pu garder un chien parce qu'il eut
causé trop de dégâts parce que les
voisins se plaignaient parce qu'ils
risquaient un procès les chiens parfois
meurent de trop aimer
alors je vous dis ces chiens qui sont
euthanasiés pour ça ce n'est plus
supportable parce qu'aujourd'hui ces
chiens nous savons les soigner et nous
savons les guérir il me reste à
présenter des excuses des excuses à
toutes les espèces que j'aurais pu citer
comme exemple merveilleux d'amour et
d'attachement les orangs outans les
maires orangs outans qui protège
tellement bien leur enfant les pères à
lamentin avec qui nous partageons ce
privilège que la paternité
mais dix sont tous ils sont tous avec
moi pour vous dire que nous pouvons être
fiers de la part animale qui est en nous
elle est ce qui nous fait palpiter et
mais elle nous inscrire au coeur du
monde
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]